in a major shift Democrats now prefer
Joe Biden to be the nominee this is very
interesting based on a Marist opinion
poll released a few days ago a major
shift has now put a plurality of
Democrats 50 percent and
democratic-leaning Independence saying
we should have Biden as the nominee in
2024. now 50 is not an explosively
beautiful number but it is a plurality
when you compare to those who say it
should be someone else or those who
don't know or those who aren't sure or
whatever the case may be this is a big
shift from November when 54 percent of
Democrats and Democratic leaning
Independents thought it should be
someone else now the plurality says it
should be Biden this is super
interesting particularly because Joe
Biden has not yet officially announced
that he is running for re-election in
2024. Trump has announced it announced
it very early the Republican primaries
getting going where are you on this
issue